I'd done that in my relationship my
woman needed an announcement girl you're
talking to you no but that's what I'm
trying to say like men are they're
spoiling the market there's so many men
out here spoiling the damn market and
spoiling women in a way which they get
used to yeah and then when the next guy
comes along she's already been spoiled
by this next guy and not because and
that guy that spoiled her didn't even
want to be with her essentially he was
just doing it to to try and be nice but
you guys do it for women that deserve it
and so and that's what I've done in my
relationship yeah but that's what I'm
saying like outside of that a lot of
girls a lot of girls don't ask me for
nothing a lot of girls feel entitled to
that but if you're not getting it you
don't deserve it how do you how do you
how do you come up with the entitlement
aspect where does that come where does
that come from so for example so just to
give an example you're going out with a
guy on the first date this is your first
date so where does this inflated sense
of importance come from how can you put
that forth as your best foot do you get
what I mean it can't but because once
you start dating that person it's just
going to get more and more and more and
more and then you're not going to be
able to keep up do you see what I'm
saying so it's unrealistic
and this is what when it goes back to
the fairy tale that's one
we're fed this fairy tale that you
should get X Y and Z you should be
treated like this and whatever it is
without it's like you're saying like we
need to talk to each other first you
need to talk you can't just get up and
say I'm going on a date without actually
knowing the person properly I think
there's no point I mean depending on the
type of date sorry the type of date do
not women do they talk amongst other
women and they say you know what yeah
you know when it takes me on a date he's
got to do this and he's got to do that
and he's got to do that and he's got to
do this he's got to do that and then and
then men yeah that say hang on a minute
no oh if you're broke just say so yeah
but it's like yo what I'm hearing here
sorry but what I'm hearing here is that
like men are allowed to have
expectations of women
and women are not no your expectations
are too high you're asking for men don't
have high expectations because
when I have conversations with the
random you just realize it's so simple
and straightforward you're like oh wow
cool but that's something that we need
to do more of we need to actually have
conversations with each other because as
women you are surrounded within women
you are surrounded with
a circle that's just like you so if you
don't know
the opposite it's gonna be a problem and
that's what's happening now I've always
heard that it's like sex sandwiches and
silence that's that's exactly right yeah
that's a men want sorry I've got to roll
out okay see you Sarah
I was wondering who's that was
awesome no I've heard that it's it's sex
sandwiches in silence and that's that's
what men want
um
silence like they want us to shut the
[ __ ] up they don't like you talking I
don't want to shut the [ __ ] up sorry
okay I know but then you make it about
you no it's not about me but why why
should I keep my mouth shut what if I've
got like goals in life what if I've got
things listen I gotta leave y'all make
me want to stay I I must shut up don't
talk to your girlfriends you talk to my
girlfriends but I still want to talk to
my man that's that's like a headache
like like why is it headache who's your
partner it shouldn't be a headache at
all you can talk
but you're thinking like a woman
you're meant to be a woman but I'm
telling you you should look at this from
the man's point of view men don't use as
many words as we do daily so they want
silence women want to talk a lot so why
don't we just talk to each other and let
them like because if a woman stays
silent again something is brewing up
inside of her basically she might catch
you well I'm not talking about I'm not
talking about passive aggressiveness I'm
talking about men want peace
sorry you have to work together you know
what's a bit messed up like it's like
for a lot of women it's very confusing
because they will be with one guy here
they will do all of this and the
relationship still won't go well they'll
be with another guy they'll do the exact
opposite of what you're saying it'll be
an issue some women can shut the [ __ ] up
as to the High Heavens and they will
still sorry to make it so extreme but
they will still get battered it's like
there's nothing sometimes I feel like
there's there's not enough that you can
do but you just keep painting the women
as the
victims you just took the extreme they
get battered but they do that it's not
the majority of women the majority so
I'm saying like you're saying oh what if
we give men what they want we might get
better like that that's a fear at the
same time you're saying they do I'm
saying that there's situations where
they do but okay but then it's still it
always come back to us like I just think
we should take accountability we either
need to learn to pick better or be
better Partners
sometimes these are sorry but these are
some of them are high value men you
think that they're high value men you
think that they're good men they're
going to treat you well X Y and Z but
then that means that men are clearly not
packaging themselves how they say and
how they sometimes even how they act
sometimes a man can act however he
behaved you see it in the actions you
think he's a good guy and it turns out
to be completely different so it's very
very confusing for women of today I feel
like it's like you just don't know what
you're gonna get well then then you
should learn to pick better
learn to pick better but everyone's good
at lying everyone's good at deceiving
everyone's good at pretending to be
something they're not but also too we do
not so are women no but I'm not saying
just yeah but I'm saying in both parties
everyone can like everyone can do
whatever but the problem is we don't
have actual conversations to decipher
what kind of person you're right but
we've said we've said this uh multiple
times in different ways it's about core
values if you are talking to a man and
your first questions aren't about you
know your core values why why would this
progress it's true you know and I think
holding accountability for your part to
play in The Suffering in a relationship
it takes two tatango as they say right
so it's a contribution from both sides
nobody's perfect we understand that
um but at the same time you do not want
to take the victim position because then
that means that you're not taking
accountability for your part to play in
the problem
sometimes so quick thing when there are
situations where no one's taking
accountability that's why it's so
helpful to go for these like mediations
and counseling because someone on
outside can look into what you are blind
yeah but what I'm but my point is if you
if you discern this early on you will
not have to go through all of that but
sometimes I feel people
choose like they can see something but
they choose to like turn a blind eye to
it before yeah
for a period of time because you know
how like women I feel like a lot of
women see a man as
uh not his purpose potential potential
yes you meet someone to see them
potentially you don't meet someone to be
like oh I see you you what am I gonna
like they say about you you're sorry
you're just to say what my point is is
when you have a conversation with this
potential future you know your man
you have to ask questions that discern
the information you need to know if you
don't know what the man's goals are from
early on why are you here if you don't
know if the man wants a family why are
you here if you don't understand his
family Dynamic why are you here do you
get me what relationships he already has
established will show you a lot about
the type of man he is
um I just wanted to say and with that
information you can make a decision